hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video today were back on monster on a
world again doing a solo guy I know I've
done a lot of these I apologize but I
have to get through all the cast of
course so that everyone can get a chance
to experience the characters and how to
do the guides just in case anybody's
stuck so that's why but today we're
gonna be talking about casual adora he's
one of the three dragons that you find
any footprints quest where you can track
the ancient dragons tracks he is located
in the elder recess now I said this in
my last guy when I talked about Valle
Haziq but if you need help on trying to
find where the tracks are you check one
of my previous videos I did a video on
how to get those three tracks the
fastest so definitely check that out if
you need it and now that's over with
we're gonna talk about the sociology
report and move into the recommended
gear so let's get started so going off
the sociology report it says that
Casillas head legs and tail are his weak
points with the head wings and tail
being breakable or severable if you're
wheeling a melee weapon you definitely
want to aim for the head and for range
weapons you should aim for the tail you
can't aim for the legs but they do the
least damage and obviously you want to
maximize as much damage as possible
these are the best places over to the
right it shows the elements and ailments
the recommended elements you should be
using against him is thunder and dragon
thunder being the best and if we're
using ailments definitely want to go for
poison or blast going off the
recommended gear obviously weapon and
armor are your choice but I would mostly
focus on good defense regarding your
armor but for the equipment you're going
to be using mega potions for obvious
reasons the vitality mantle is also a
good idea to negate some incoming damage
and probably the most necessary thing
for this whole flight is flash pods if
you do need some flash pods there are
usually some flash bugs I believe
there's about three of them on the left
side of wild spire waste usually towards
the top or middle of the map on the left
side you can go on farm though and or
you can also farm these at the
harvesting plant area at astera those
are probably going to be the most
necessary if you do want to bring
anything else that's completely up to
you but these are the three things that
I recommend now that is over with we're
gonna be looking at cashew his moveset
as well as the areas you can find him in
and see if we can get a little bit of a
tactical advantage let's start with the
move set
so first up in his moveset is this
little quick attack where he swings his
head a little bit and shoots air that
will do some damage it's nothing crazy
it's pretty easy attacks one of his
basic ones and will only happen if
you're right in front of him but
nonetheless it is a move he has so
definitely watch out for that cashews
will also tend to fly in the air most of
the time this is where the flash pods
will come in
we'll get to that he would leave a mini
tornado where he is before you before he
takes off you cannot enter this tornado
and if you get too close you'll be
knocked away and you won't be able to
move for a bit and being open for an
attack you can only enter this tornado
if you have the rock steady mantle but
that can only be achieved from a hunter
rank 50 quest so if you're watching this
I'm assuming you're not there yet and
it's all good because neither am i well
in the air his most common move is the
dive bomb where he tries to ply you over
by flying toward you simply sprint
jumping and rolling and in general we
good enough to dodge it also while in
the air he will try to shoot Wendy you
this does a tad bit of damage and knocks
you back you could just sprint away from
these or dodge roll like normal he will
also try to dive-bomb you before landing
on the ground so definitely watch out
for that another move he likes to throw
in while he's on the ground is too quick
forward swipes which will always go to
the right and then to left like in this
clip shown while in the air kasuga can
also fly up to you and try to scratch
you with his claws obviously dodging
will be will avoid this from hitting you
one huge move that does some damage is
this air blast attack where he stands up
on his hind legs and then blows air you
look cannon dealing tons of damage if
hit by it quick note though at any time
khushu is in the air you can flash
bought him to bring him down and get
some free damage just like in this clip
he gets in the air and immediately gets
put back down with the flash pods I've
also been told that bright Moss can also
work if you shoot him in the head with
it but I have yet to accomplish this and
now that his moveset is done let's move
to the areas you vitamin so the first
one that I fought him in is this
decently open area and the only really
useful things and there is a couple
ledges to either hide from casual if you
need to heal or Mountain next area is
this huge open area with a downhill
slope it is actually the same exact area
that your fight over gone in but on the
floor there are some explosive neuro
toads and para toads that will either do
blast damage or paralyze him depending
on which one you choose and I believe
there's also about three or four of them
in this area so definitely use those
when you have the chance you can also
use the sliding attack on this really
long inclined or decline slope do some
damage as well or mount them if possible
next area is also this Crystal Room in
the area there are some crystal bursts
you can use this slinger mo against
Casula this will stun him for a bit if
he's in the middle of an attack as well
as little plants that one cut will give
you health if you need some extra health
super quick without having to use a
potion also someone on miner Gurgaon say
guide mentioned that there is a crystal
on the ceiling that does some crazy
damage if it lands on him I couldn't
find it on the on the map but I assume
you just used a slinger to knock it down
so
only look up with the ceiling and use
that to your advantage and then lastly
is his nest this place is a little bit
difficult to fight him but not too much
only because the mini tornados he makes
blocks paths because obviously you can't
walk through them and since it's an open
area it's not as open as opposed to the
other areas we fought him in you don't
have too much room to fight him so but
to get there you'll have to climb all
the way up from the top you can use the
wedge beetles at the very top to fling
yourself just aim at them and press B or
circle depending on what you're playing
on and regarding the area he sleeps on
this rocky place in the middle and you
can use that to ledge him as well if you
get up there and he's on the ground as
well as the area behind you with some
much higher elevation you can also use
that same spot to do a sliding attack as
well and that's it I hope this helped
you beat casual adora he's not really
hard in my opinion he he does like to
stay up in the air a lot so that is one
of the big problems when I used to when
I fought him the first time it took me a
very long time to fight him I almost ran
out of time but the flash pods are
definitely a very necessary thing
to keep the fight going and not stalling
while he's just flying up in the air
doing moves that you're clearly dodging
but with that guys hope you guys enjoyed
the video please should give it a like
if you did subscribe if you're new I
cover a lot of Monster Hunter content so
far I'm doing a lot of solo guides I'm
still finishing up the other characters
as well and the other ones in the hunter
rank 29 and 50 stuff that I'll be
covering when I once I get to that but
then I'm also going to be doing some
other Monster Hunter content when that
comes by stuff we stick around for that
so like I said subscribe before new buy
two most recent Monster Hunter videos
gonna be puffing up on screen if you
guys need to check those out it's
completely fine with me when that guys I
hope you have a great rest your day and
peace out